bella a tutti i ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo nuovo video io sono fan i j
oggi siamo di nuovo su the witch house
abbiamo abbiamo fatto un casino l'ultima
volta è successo di tutto
ma c'è dell'altro quest'altra porto che
non avevo ancora visto promette
veramente bene ragapiano di barili e si
spostano pure fantastico c'è allora mi
ricordo che hanno spesso bisogno ce l'ho
scritto una corda nei barili da qualche
parte quindi dovrebbe esserci una corda
né barile
una libreria piena di ragnatele nulla
all'interno perfetto da nomi una
farfalla david e butterfly vi ricordate
ce l'ha scritto la porta devo salvare la
farfalla da premi la prendi la prendi lo
ha preso la farfalla bene l'ho salvata e
devo trovare un accordo di barili
ragazza niente devo scacciarli in
qualche modo ma non so come c'è anche
qualcosa di scritto di ma non ci arriva
devo prima distruggere i barili in
qualche modo da me torniamo indietro la
porta non si apre cosa vuol dire che la
porta non si apre addio
cos'è sta roba oh cazzo solo un raglio
stato appoggiato da un ragno merda non
voleva essere baciato da un ruolino il
centro più fan cola va dalla parte
opposta dove dovevo andare alla pace uno
spec innanzitutto sono [ __ ] sono molto
[ __ ] un libro intitolato una bella una
storia felice va bene è una storia
divertente scusatemi comunque once beh
sì vabbè magari sono traduca meglio una
volta tempo fa c'era un ricco uomo che
spingeva un carrello pieno di tesori il
suo carrello siro si ruppe e cade nel
bosco ma dopo di che passarono fantasma
il suo e il suo cane è ricco uomo su
piccolo spettro perché potesse tenere
d'occhio suo carrello
finché lo space finché lo spettro non
non acconsentì rico comando a cercare un
nuovo carrello comunque è lo spettro
rimane a guardare
una volta scesa la notte lo spettro si
preoccupò per la sua vecchia madre che
era ancora a casa quindi lo spettro di
saccani di due di tenere l'occhio il
carrello e e torno a casa da sua mamma
quando l'uomo ritorno a v del cane che
faceva la guardia così diede che hanno
un premio per la sua maestria una moneta
d argento che li portò nella sua bocca e
charlie ritorno a casa portando la
moneta suo maestro allo spettro si
arrabbia ha detto di guardare il
carrello e tu che cosa hai fatto hai
rubato dal carrello e climi maestro c6
cane ma che cazzo ti vidi che non faceva
ridere
resta una storia divertente dio mio
ragazzi vi siete divertiti un mondo ios
e ragazzi non chiedetevi che cosa è
servito tutto questo ma non ne ho idea
vabbè comunque qua c'è scritto amica
ecco salva la farfalla il problema che
non voglio salvare la farfalla perché
c'è un ragno della madonna
senti mi puoi dare una mano ti prego so
che ti puoi muovere fatto prima o poi di
fare cagare a dozza quindi nuovi di
primavera che mi sa che ci devo andare
per forza allora fatemi capire un attimo
c'è una cena ricordano i barile perfetto
l'ho trovato ho preso una corda perfetto
via di qua vi è la il cazzo subito devo
devo farmi devo fare qualcosa costa
accordo che è successo mi sembrate che
si muovesse ma deve essere la tua
immaginazione
devo andare avanti poi l'uomo invisibile
non so che cosa volevo fare vista corda
ma tienitela mi stai dando questo si
tratti sta dando corda va bene grazie
prego prego prego c'è di che per lo
prenderò va bene
quando prendi lo ho ricevuto il libro
della morte
bene avendo un libro a lei che lo
rispetto a quelli di prima io ho visto
ti ho visto brutto stronzo non mi fossi
stato visto abbiamo ricevuto il libro
della morte cioè il cavaliere che se l'è
svignata maledetto tu non hai detto
niente verona brutto stronzo ad un gatto
non serve a nulla
devo devo mettere il libro qui prima di
andare avanti comunque perché c'è un
libro della morte e manca libro nella
libreria quindi io direi di inserirlo
vai libro della morte legge o non legge
non vorrei leggerlo ma lo leggiamo a sto
punto va bene sediamoci a leggere si sta
commuovendo non hai letto niente
cosa sta facendo si sta vedendo se
allergica libri ci viene l'irritazione
con scasso fa chissà cosa cazzo praga
cosa è successo
ho letto un libro raga io lo so che io
ho sempre detto che leggeri di bruccini
e cioè nessuno mi ha mai ascoltato ma
credetemi che uccide
vabbè all ho letto un libro e sono morta
se trovate delle spiegazioni a tutto
questo fatemelo sapere
vabbè io direi di inserirlo senza
leggerlo stavolta c'era un motivo se si
chiamava libero della morte non lo legge
va bene mettiamolo solo vai lo leggerà
qualcun altro spero il cavaliere
ho sentito il rumore di un vetro che
cadeva vero non sia la vetrina degli
insetti ma qualcosa mi dice che lo è
perché mi sono appena fermato senza
motivo e tutto normale vero essere
strutturato in un teschio all'ordine del
giorno
vabbè devo fare qualcosa tipo forse a
girarlo mentre arriva vai vai vai corri
corri subito marie jeanne e il botto
brutto aspetto quando è andato a puntare
non me ne frega niente allora andiamo
indietro
fammi salvare prima che mi sto per dzeko
va bene ed è tornato indietro che è
caduto il quadro infatti i teschi non
c'è più decaduto qualcosa il quadro di
un gatto gol con della lana benissimo
allora non sai cadute basta cioè non
sapeva nulla bene maledizione perché non
capisco che cosa devo fare qui perché ho
controllato tutta l'ora i vetri ci sono
ecc
cos'è sta roba qui ho trovato una
farfalla ma [ __ ] è un ora che giro
ma l'inizio nella v vista prendila
ottenuto il modellino di una farfalla da
ragazzi
forse ho capito come si deve fare è più
brutto stronzo perché sei tornato chi ti
ha detto di tornare più maledetto
stronzo ti ho visto che ti sento visto è
non giochiamo a due tre stella perché
perdita già visto io direi di andare
avanti allora dovrei riuscire a farci ha
reso la prendiamo la farfalla ok ci
dovremmo essere gli oggetti modellino di
farfalla metti sto modellino e speriamo
che sarà ok allora dovremmo fare
speriamo che al ragno non se ne
accorgono devo andare avanti domandava
ok che c'è un buco del provento lo vedo
che un buco del papi cosa devo fare qui
oggetti non metterci la farfalla che
potevo fare questo buco nel pavimento va
bene andiamo avanti noi mi servirà di
salire a dopo molto probabilmente che
la farfalla si rivela le tue mani e
passa all'interno del muro è uno spettro
farfalla fantastico è un qualcosa si è
sbloccato la vuoi che parta dalla
perfetta
dov'è il gatto che devo salvare la
bandiera è caduta al terreno la vedo sì
io pensavo ci fosse il gatto ma
evidentemente c'è la bandiera che che
che vuole prendere posto legato a vela
porta si è aperta noi entriamo speriamo
di trovare sto maledetto gatto prima di
morire
cos'è sta roba ci sono dei sacchetti che
bloccano il passato ma posso passarci
fantastica piano di sacchetti a caso
sono pacchetti di patatine perfetta ecco
il gatto fantastico gli oblò siamo
tornati ci rivediamo mi serve cos'è sta
roba perché c'è del sangue dietro le
candele non è normale
vabbè andiamo avanti lo facciamo ci
domande ci è arrivato un coltello in
pieno petto fantastico proprio una mira
eccezionale e maria e maria che è
tornato alla met father ok ragazzini
programmo rimasti ho cambiato vestiti e
tutto ma non è che sono un mago e che ho
continuato il giorno dopo perché dovevo
fare delle cose
e vabbè allora ci siamo riusciti se si
fermi la posso fare
a parte un'occasione ok perfetto
che culo speriamo nomi vecchi nulla ok
ce l'ho fatta dovevo trovare un gatto
assolutamente prima che muoia prima ok
perfetto se io ho un cazzo vai salva
comunque la casa della strega lo sai
questo era vero
lo so ma non me ne frega un cazzo salva
la partita ci siamo regalati a porte
chiuse siamo in una nuova zona
completamente e non so che come una rara
che ci parlerà nello stato a bernini
porta c'è un qualcosa ti piace o nera ne
ha voglia che mi piacciono le rane come
nel forno e vabbè comunque scuote la
testa cosa dovrebbe fare niente non so a
un qua è apparso un cuore mi sono
innamorato della rana
oddio la radio è saltato addosso mi si è
infilata nelle mutande la rana rana
porcellana dov'è andato a finire bene
non si è capita sta cosa ma veniamo
avanti un po de veramente stretto nuova
aspettate voi pensate che io debba
raggiungerà la leva laggiù c'è devo
essere che cazzo sono un funambolo come
faccio
guarda attraverso che ne so la vedo la
leva è più sottile nella tua gamba e si
spezzerebbe in ogni secondo sottopeso
vabbè io comunque non pensavo di andarci
e attraversa veramente attraversiamo
solo per vedere in che modo muoio perché
sono curiosissimo chiamava non mi potevo
aspettare di meglio sinceramente
e vabbè tanto sapevo che schiacciava era
solo per vedere come faccia attraverso
allora forse con la rana aspettate un
attimo che la rana l'ho presa vai mai la
rana poi attraverso la rana è un
suicidio poverino perché addio grande
storia è una pazza bene e ho sentito il
rumore di qualcosa e si è sbloccato va
bene speriamo che riesca a tornare
indietro
ok ti voglio bene anch'io bravissima il
pil ha timore le mutande e andiamo
avanti
un giorno guardi che di là il ponte e
sottile chi pazzo era quella ragazza è
passato qualcuno e non so chi fossero
noi da va bene di salvia mandiamo avanti
la porta si aperta vai cos'è che sta
diventando sempre più strano ma mano che
vado avanti e prendi la torcia una torta
qui dentro ho preso un pezzo di torta
ho trovato un pezzo di torta
nell'armadio giustamente che ce n'è un
altro
[Musica]
cosa devo farcela rara qui c'è un'altra
rana però questa è finta stato fa la
porta è chiusa benissimo penso che forse
io debba mettere la x solito cos'è cazzo
sta succedendo ho capito ho capito
madonna mia aver giocato a mente father
mi è servito a qualcosa raga
praticamente devo far sì che la stanza
sia uguale da entrambe le parti allora
questa la devo spingere ce l'ho fatta ci
ho messo un'ora e mezza madonna mi hanno
messo veramente cos'è lo si è visto
perché ti stai girando cosa cosa c'è lui
stand alla rana forse devo prenderne che
dopo prenderà una te scusami piccola mia
abbiamo pensato aveva andiamo allora
ragazzi ci sia ci ho messo veramente
un'ora e mezza c'è una cosa impossibile
il diario della strega aspetta che qua
c'è una nota un'altra quindi visto
attraverso la prossima porta fa che
nulla ti distragga se proprio devo va
bene c'è il diario nelle altre gare
leggiamo mio padre mia madre non mi
amavano e quindi io ipse idem
penso voglia dire che il gioco uccisi e
sono rimasti in questa casa fino a che
allora ragazzi dobbiamo far sì che nulla
ci distragga allora dobbiamo stare
attenti
speriamo di riuscirci vado avanti oddio
cos'era un coltello lo scrivano di
brutto perché sia infiniti è una stanza
bellissima tal ci sono le orme su merda
siamo stati schiacciati da una roccia
grande ma non dobbiamo farci distrarre
in quel senso se non mi colpisce il
coltello credo ma [ __ ] doveva
andar dritto e non avevo capito a sta
cosa che allora c'è della roba a destra
c'è un qualcosa lì era gay non ci vado
perché sto già chi ha detto che tanto
muoio perché non devo farmi distrarlo
che vado avanti ok ci siamo lui ha fame
è sì li preparo qualcosa se vuoi ma noi
andiamo avanti ragazzi non ha senso c'è
qualcosa dall'altra parte cosa guarda la
porta origlia oppure aprile ea aprì la
porta a sto punto è storia non dovrei
farlo ma lo faccio perché non so che
cosa c'è era veramente un basilisco dove
cazzo harry potter quando serve
raga forse ho capito cosa devo fare ma
non so come ok gli ho dato la rana o mio
dio una poverina perché devo sacrificare
la rana la rana sta facendo l'esistenza
forza la
va bene la rana è stata buttata nel buco
e ragazzi sacrificata la rana era mia
amica perché ho fatto non senti niente
raga dove adesso sono andato a prima la
porta dai davvero sia prima perché
dovrebbe sto se n'è andato raga mi
spiace per la rana però domanda davanti
c'è un grande books terreno d'ora di
sangue io lì non ci vado grazie mille
vado di qui avete visto anche voi
e successo raga lo zio usciamo di qua
cos'è cioè prima misura è apparsa la
rana qua
e va bene non ho capito bene cosa è
successo ma va bene così deve essere
senso di colpa per aver sacrificato la
rana vabbè mi dispiace prodotto farlo la
statua di un gatto il cazzo di gatto sia
anche mosso presso che la sua testa si
sia mossa si si è mossa l'ho vista è un
altro gatto
no questo non si muova permette un altro
gatto ma acqua c'è il gatto vero la
statua di un gatto si sto scherzando
lo so che non sto scherzando non
ignorarmi oh mio dio io lo amo sempre di
più sul gatto vi giuro
e sappiamo la partita perfetta tra
queste sono ancora state normali si cela
solo quella la fine che s'è mossa
no veramente siamo fan che questa si sia
mossa l'ho visto era tipo l'esorcista
vadano avanti e ci sono delle scale
ragazzi non so dove sto andando poi
soltanto dove l'occhio è aperto quale
occhio questa è una bocca aperta questa
è un'altra volk aperto è quello gli
occhi sono aperti ed è inquietante da
morire però io devo andare di qua si può
posso entrare qui dentro entriamo gli
occhi sono aperti quindi ho seguito alla
lettera non sono matto ma dai blocchi e
disegnato sul muro l'occhio disegnato
sul muro ho capito cos'è il prezzo fatto
tu hai fatto a scoprire cosa ho cliccato
raga non ho capito cos'è i miei occhi su
di sé il syraka ok adesso c'è un occhio
solo aperto ma va a cagare che ne sapevo
se io dovevo praticamente unire massima
chi ci sarebbe mai arrivato ci arrivato
per culo la faccia mi ha guardato l'ho
vista che brutta cosa
eh vabbè ci siamo infatti madonna
guardate dove l'ho finito prima mio dio
che cosa macabra è un bagno avanti
ragazzi ci stiamo qua ci sono delle
punte non ci va perché dovrei chi è
quella sotto chi c'è raga
c'è qualcuno qui sotto l'ho visto l'ho
vista ma che mi sta spaventando sa cosa
vi giuro io direi il concludere qui poi
questo episodio non è solito sei video è
piaciuto lasciato un commento mi piace
anche alla pagina di facebook e come non
i video trovate nella descrizione sensi
tacco rischi di iscrivetevi noi ci
vediamo in un prossimo video bella
ragazzi